des plages vidées de leurs touristes des
établissements qui affiche portes closes
et des milliers d'employés au chômage
voici ce qu'est devenue la carte postale
de cet endroit paradisiaque nocibé est
habituellement la première destination
touristique de madagascar celle qui vit
exclusivement de ses visiteurs et coupé
du reste du monde depuis le 20 mars
dernier et la fermeture des frontières
que jean-michel alexandre comme tous les
opérateurs touristiques cherche des
solutions pour ne pas laisser ses
employés sans revenus mais son
entreprise de circuit n'a plus de
clients a baladés motif de cette sortie
en pirogue avec son associé les guides
locaux planifier plus d'offres pour
mieux préparer le retour des touristes
étant donné que nocive et vit sur sur le
tourisme
on est frappé de plein fouet non pas par
le corona mais finalement parlé décision
d'arrêter tourisme donc on se retrouve
avec des centaines de familles dans une
précarité
il faut qu'on trouve tous ensemble des
solutions pour que les gens je dirais
tout simplement mange donc effectivement
si tu as une partie de la population qui
ne mange pas on risque d'avoir des
soucis expatrié depuis 20 ans dans
l'océan indien
ce belge a démarré son activité à nocibé
en 2018
il fait vivre six familles grâce à sa
société de circuits touristiques en
toutou qu'électrique les grands hôtels
fermés depuis une semaine ont dû mettre
en congé des centaines de personnes les
14 plus grand établissement de nocibé
regroupe une masse salariale d'une
valeur de 115 millions euros mensuels
750 personnes sont sur la sellette
l'état malgache planche sur un plan de
secours pour maintenir l'emploi à mi
temps face à cette crise un climat
d'insécurité règne sur l'île des
premiers cas de vols ont eu lieu
un français a même été assassiné dans
son domicile je dirais même pas peur
mais fermeture de suspension des vols y
aura peut-être beaucoup qui vont quand
même perdre de l'emploi où seront en
chômage partiel donc ça peut donner des
idées
paquereau je dirais catholique donc du
coup comment renforcer là
sécurité donc là aussi à des idées qui
se sont soulevés en bougeant il faut
renforcer la sécurité comment le faire
et que chacun de pouvoir participer à
cette protection je dirais à 7 minutes
contre l'insécurité des mesures
radicales pour éviter que madagascar
tombe dans le chaos
la plupart des habitants survivent avec
moins de deux euros par jour et les
quelques trois cent mille touristes qui
visitent le pays chaque année génère des
emplois pour 641 mille malgache sur une
population de 26 millions d'habitants
c'est tout à fait logique dans une
période de crise de ce type c'est à dire
c'était la fin du jeu par rapport à la
pandémie mais par conséquence on va voir
aussi en deuxième
une crise économique
l'argent donc prévoyez une sécurité
renforcée
je ne veux pas affoler les gens je dis
juste ou vendeuses de fer intentions
pour eux pour leur entourage de
sécuriser l'endroit où ils habitent
d'éviter de des provocations en est en
en exhibant de l'argent et autres bien
entendu les derniers touristes ont dû
quitter l'île de nocibé laissant tout ce
qu'il faisait vivre dans le désarroi
la perte de madagascar aux eaux
cristallines s'apprête à traverser l'une
des pires crises sociale de son histoire